thank you very much and just master's
Reverend Fowler ladies and gentlemen
thank you for your welcome and it's a
pleasure to be here at the Center for
Strategic and International Studies and
I didn't expect to be the headline act
for the beginning of the new decade
happy to be here this morning as has
been said it's the first visit to the
United States a straight Commissioner
it's the first of what I expect to be
many visits to Washington as European
Trade Commissioner and of course as an
Irishman coming to the United States you
feel very much at home I had a very busy
few days here already and a lot of
meetings scheduled today meeting members
of the administration members of the
Senate members of the Congress and key
think tanks and people who think the
think tanks have ideas about what's
going on and these are very important
meetings from terms of outreach and
dialogue of understanding each other and
where the European Union is coming from
and the meetings that have had the main
very positive and productive from the
confirm that there are powerful and
influential voices on both sides of the
Atlantic calling for political
leadership to refresh to recalibrate and
generally reclaim the shared agenda and
trade between the United States near and
and if we go about this in the right way
of working together the mutual benefits
can be very significant but if we fail
to do so the damage will be significant
on some not alone for us both but for
the world we have built together
so we were entering this decade at a
pivotal moment in time and we are faced
with many challenges many of which are
totally new it is important that we make
the right chine choices now in the
direction we go and the choice above all
is this we either cooperate and shape
the response to these challenges
together or these challenges will shape
divided and diminishes so ladies and
gentlemen you are all very familiar with
our rich shared history of global
leadership in the
but in many other areas as well the
United States and the European Union are
each other's most important partner and
we have for decades shared an
international outlook and values that
are ruthless in our intertwined history
together we shaped a global trading
system and the mutual multilateral
institutions that governors and this is
allowed us to build an economic
partnership that has become the most
significant commercial artery in the
world and together we formed the largest
and wealthiest global market with
overall trade in goods and services
worked over 1.3 trillion annually
working together we have been the engine
of sustained global prosperity for many
decades but the sense of global trade
are shifting and the last decade in
particular has seen fundamental shifts
trade politics is no longer exclusively
about trade policy it is often a proxy
for security technology geopolitics and
more in particular trade has become a
tool in the global struggle for
technological supremacy other more
general megatons of accelerators a rate
of nuts such as digitalization and
technological advances the rise of China
climate change global demographic shifts
and a recognition of the impact of
international trade on workers and
farmers the combined weight of these
changes means we are now experiencing a
high-pressure crisis a high-pressure
crisis moment for the international
trading system however as we know
diamonds are made under pressure and the
EU was treating this as an opportunity
to crystallize our priorities and to
assert them on the world stage I
sincerely hope that the United States is
thinking along the same lines in the
European Union we are we're not going to
retreat into our shell at this critical
moment in international relations we're
very much open for business
and we believe in the opportunity of
openness new European Commission
President our Slav underline is taking a
strong geopolitical
approach to all of our policy woman she
has given a clear commitment that we
need a positive balanced and mutually
beneficial trading in partnership with
the United States and she has given a
clear commitment that we need to
elaborate and how we can move a little
faster in that direction first of all in
the interest of transparency and fair
play we need to measure our trade
relationship with the right metrics it's
always good to know where the staffing
position is we must call out the
narrative that the United States has a
trade deficit or an unfair trading
relationship with the European Union in
reality the relationship is bought
balanced and highly mutually beneficial
and this cannot be stated enough in fact
the fact the facts are clear our tariffs
in the United States in the European
Union are very similar on industrial
tariffs our weighted average supply
tariff is 1.4 percent the United States
tariffs on the EU is 1.6 percent the
inclusion of Agriculture which many
politicians are looking for in any
negotiations between the European Union
in the United States changes the picture
very slightly the EU weighted average on
all US imports stands at 3 percent if
you include agriculture where's the US
tariff in EU imports at 2.4 percent so
these are figures that I wanted to give
you in order to show that the nur of the
narrative of what has been said about
this massive deficit is actually
misplaced the modern economy trades and
goods services and investment and each
of these creates jobs and salaries for
American workers
the u.s. is a services led economy in
fact the u.s. is the global services
powerhouse
American services exports to the
European Union among two hundred and
fifty six billion dollars in 2080
a surplus of sixty billion dollars all
of its strongly supporting jobs and
wealth right here in the United States
of America on top of that American
companies in the European Union sent
back 123 billion dollars to the United
States every year
so transatlantic trade in goods and
services
worked over three billion dollars a day
so it sounds like a fairly healthy
relationship in trade terms to me
mutual investment is another pillar of
the transatlantic economy and in the
last decade alone the United the
European Union has attracted over 58
percent of total US foreign investment
US companies freely choose to invest
more in the European Union than another
any other markets combined and that in
all other markets combined this is a
highly profitable enterprise for
American companies who have an
investment staff in Europe of three
point six trillion dollars of course
this Halep also applies in the other
direction 60 percent of foreign
investment in the United States comes
from the European Union it should be
noted that 66% of all EU imports that
require further processing and further
production in the United States which
means more jobs in the United States
this has never taken into account in any
of the trade narrative that I hear about
so why then would you be putting tariffs
on these European products that are
needed for further processing in
production and for jobs in the United
States to make them more expensive for
your people more expensive for your
business and this damages employment
damages economic activity in the medium
term so we can say beyond any doubt that
the transatlantic economic relationship
is a balanced one it's a multi-layered
one and above all one it's very
beneficial to both sides these are
important facts that should be fostered
and strengthened the European Union is a
free and open market offering a level
playing field to US companies that's why
they're there 500 million people other
partners do not do so because the
transatlantic supply chains allow
companies in the European Union the u.s.
to operate more efficiently together and
secure millions of jobs on both sides of
the Atlantic 16 million jobs at the last
count no other market is is free and
open for US businesses the EU where else
are you as welcome I might add I'm
coming under pressure to defend this
level of openness given that our
European business
can be hit with John justified tariffs
and restrictions at a moment's notice
but I want to be clear that we reject
the u.s. labeling the EU as a security
risk in order to justify the imposition
of tariffs the narrow service is hurtful
to our European people the EU was
absolutely committed to a strong and
positive bilateral agenda and I'm here
this week to try and develop that
positive agenda the executive working
group that was established by President
Trump and President jean-claude Juncker
in July 2018 has done some good work it
has reduced tensions and encouraged
cooperation of both the bilateral agenda
and global challenges from our side we
are already delivering some results
take for example our increase in imports
of American savings which President
Trump likes and liquefied natural gas
this increase in imports is good for US
farmers and exporters but also for
energy diversification and
agriculturally you so it's a good
example of a win-win but improvements in
trade should not be one way so the EU
has been patient for many years since
2008 to receive approval for the modest
exportation of apples and pears to the
United States from the European Union
and I'm often asked to explain the
scientific basis of why certain products
are blocked from access to the European
Union by the United States I questioned
the scientific basis for blocking the
approval of apples and pears as well
into the United States after 12 years so
Europe is a major export destination for
our United States farmers last year we
imported some 14 billion dollars of
American agricultural products in fact
we like your product so much that angry
food imports in the United States are
the fastest growing EU imports in
addition we grants the EU s
exclusive use of 35,000 tonnes of our
import port for hormone-free beef we
adjusted that quota to at the request of
the United States and we did it with a
good heart this is out of a total of
45,000 tons of beef that comes in home
and free into the European Union and
this is operation from the first
January 2020 so these are good news
stories but we're ambitious for more and
we want to find a laser negotiations on
issues of a United States concern where
they have put on the table issues around
conformity assessment which is a
long-standing ask of the United States
we want to discuss tariffs and how we
can reduce tariffs but also reduce
non-tariff barriers we need more
convergence in relation to standards and
in the regulatory field through greater
cooperation this is the best way for
both of us to be rule makers instead of
rule takers ongoing negotiations and
these are important and if we don't work
together on these issues somebody else
and some other country will do it we are
keen to intensify our cooperation and
technology covering areas as
semiconductors artificial intelligence
additive manufacturing and quantum
technology this cooperation will be
massively important for our economies
and our security in the future and the
European Union followed the u.s. example
and introduced its own investment
screening mechanism in recent times and
we're eager to learn from the
experiences of the United States in
relation to export control and
investment screening to name but a few
so we can protect our trusted
transatlantic trade and investment space
and we should have discussions on a
possible agreement to whitelist each
other when it comes to investment in
export controls but we recognize these
are only the four steps we need to
cooperate much more closely and the
technologies that are transforming our
economies in order to protect our
trusted trading space the EO breeze and
the importance of telecom network
security particularly in relation to 5g
the European Commission in fact
published an eu-wide risk assessment in
October 2019 in respect of this area and
this month the EU and the member states
will present a toolbox of mitigating
measures to address these risks this
work will provide a good foundation for
future transatlantic cooperation an area
of great concern to this administration
so we're laying the foundation of our
for a shared future for decades to come
by openly discussing these issues with
our friends in the United States however
we must also deal with the disputes of
the present day imposing tariffs on each
other serves nobodies long-term interest
tariffs are in reality just another form
of Taxation on businesses and consumers
there are no winners in a trade war you
don't have to take my word for it the
Federal Reserve study released last
month by the United States shows that
the import tariffs imposed to protect US
manufacturers have had the opposite
effect by raising input costs and by
triggering retaliatory tariffs this
reduces economic growth reduces wages
and puts jobs at risk it's hardly a
sensible approach in this regard I
regret the choice of the United States
to move ahead with tariffs in the Airbus
case and the recent announcement to
potentially subject additional EEO
products the tariffs this leaves the
European Union with no alternative but
to follow through in due course with our
own tariffs in relation to the Boeing
case which will be announced in May or
June with it at the WTO where the United
States has been found in breach of WTO
rules or rules and we have a giant
responsibility to resolve this and we've
offered to do so by negotiation we've
made proposals we haven't got really any
response yet but we are open to sitting
down and negotiating a balanced
settlement so they're Huma leave these
disputes behind us and he who has shared
concrete proposals as I said with the
United States on how we can do that
we've clearly identified aircraft
subsidies and on future support or
perspective aircraft sectors if we don't
solve this issue china will help to grow
its business in civil aviation at the
expense of the European Union in the
United States now is the time that we
can defend the position about the United
States and the EU aircraft sectors in a
market with strong emerging players if
we continue to beat each other up then
the future risks been lost to the new
competitors find the agreements also
essential in relation to
modern connected economies people in the
America in the unit and the European
Union want digital companies to
contribute their fair share of tax and
both sides of the pond of course how we
do that is what we're negotiating at the
OECD and we need to find a sustainable
answer to this problem if we want to
prevent every country coming up with his
own individual solution so we have made
it clear that we have no option but to
regulate on our own if the u.s. blocks a
global agreement through the OECD so
ladies and gentlemen we are operating in
a changing global economy and in Europe
we remain absolutely convinced and
unwavering in our conviction that an
open trading system with a firm and fair
rulebook is the best hope for every
country around the world to achieve its
a sustainable economic progress global
challenges in my view need global rules
unfortunately the Whorton rulebook is
out of date and the rules based
multilateral system has drifted away
from economic and business realities the
gap in the multilateral rulebook has
allowed China to provide significant
subsidization that distorts markets and
investment flows by creating over
capacity in certain sectors China's
state-owned enterprises are in a
position to outbid others in government
procurement or in acquisitions this
means it can exploit its role as a key
investment destination to siphon off
technology by forcing giant ventures or
requiring disclosure of trade secrets in
order to get licenses China has been
able to do all of this while maintaining
closed markets that allow its own
operators to grow by putting up internal
barriers to foreign operators such as
complex licensing requirements and
discriminatory licensing conditions that
is why the WTO of reform is a top
European priority we fully agree with
the United States that the organization
needs to be fixed and it needs a
profound overhaul not just tweaking at
the margins rulemaking is paralyzed and
transparency is underused and the cordon
rulebook does not adequately address
some of the most trade the starting
measures such as industrial subsidies
and this week the United States the
European Union Japan
together in a giant statement to reflect
this reality and her concern and our
ability to work together it's probably
the first time that those three entities
were in a photograph together for a
while and hopefully it's the start of
something new but we have to step up our
cooperation and we need a new balance to
be found in the WTO with clear rules and
commitments that properly regulate
global trade after all is an
organization that's 25 years old we need
to establish a level playing field that
reflects the world of today and the
worst global economy more connected and
technologically driven than ever before
our objective is to return the WTO to
the center of global trade where it
belongs
that is why we ordered need to fix the
negotiating function of the organization
and for this it is a total no-brainer
because the Organization has been unable
to create new rules or adapt existing
ones for far too long I therefore warmly
welcome what we did this week to try and
deal with the issues of industrial
subsidies and forced technology transfer
together and to deal with the distorting
trade the distorting issues that are
hampering the cooperation is necessary
in the rule book on global trade it
shows what can be done if we work
together rights and obligations in the
system should be rebalanced and at a
minimum right I think we can probably
agree that the so-called emerging
countries like China have emerged this
means that a fresh look is needed at the
question of exceptions for developing
countries which should only be available
where and when needed a broad exception
for two-thirds of WTO members is not
acceptable so we are in agreement with
the United States on this and we need to
define the appropriate way to get there
the WTO will need to change the way it
works negotiates and decides the
hostage-taking and consensus blocking
attitude will not work anymore and we
need mechanisms to facilitate the
integration of plurilateral approaches
in the WTO framework this would
introduce a new dynamic into the
organization and be crucial for several
negotiations that are important in the
future such as e-commerce but I repeat
what will be the value of new rules
without a proper end
foresman mechanism we therefore need an
effective dispute settlement system that
enforces the rules as we have agreed
them nobody can play the global game in
trade without a good referee to our
American friends my message is very
simple let's talk let's cooperate let's
lead we will approach any discussions in
WTO reform at an open mind and we have
made proposals to address these concerns
of the United States recently and we now
need territory in relation to what the
United States actually wants the time
has come to start discussions in earnest
and our strong preference is the tackle
WTO Reform on the basis of transatlantic
cooperation but if the United States
does not wish to engage in this work the
European Union will have to strike out
on its own with other partners so ladies
and gentlemen let me conclude by once
more wishing you a Happy New Year
and a happy new decade and I remain
hopeful after my visit here this week
that the 2020s can be an era of
refreshed and resurgent transatlantic
relationships we have a strong and
proactive trade agenda in the European
Union I can assure you that we will be
no shrinking violets we will robustly
defend our European interests but let us
recall that our primary interest and the
job we are here to do on both sides of
the Atlantic is to protect the interests
and well-being of our people and our
economies American and European
companies are relying on open markets
and if we fail to protect them in our
economies it will be our economies our
workers and our citizens who will end up
paying the price the European Union the
United States are sometimes described as
siblings and I have to say I agree with
this observation but as you know our
siblings often bicker they call each
other names from time to time they even
get into a fight but let's not forget
that when the pressure comes siblings
are family and we always end up
supporting each other so I hope to bring
it back to seeing matters eye-to-eye as
a family and this is the world's best
hope for a peaceful and prosperous
future thank you
[Applause]